- "Cherish The Day" is on Oprah's network,
and have y'all met Oprah before?
- You know I met her a long
time ago, the first movie I did
was precious, and she
was the producer on that.
So I like met her, in that mix.
But for Cherish, we
haven't officially met her.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But she was--
- [Kelly] When was that meet?
Was it officially?
- She was at the table--
- I wanna hear you!
I wanna hear! (laughs)
(laughing)
- I'm so excited!
- Because we walked in
and we were both nervous
because we, you know,
because it's everybody,
it's a table-read and this
is the point where you can
either keep the job or they fire you!
- [Kelly] Yes.
- So we were like, "we
gotta do our thing."
And we walk in and we see
her on this big television.
- Oh she's somewhere
else, she's skyping in?
- Yes, and she's skyping in.
- okay.
- Yeah well she's Oprah,
she got a lot a doing
to do and stuff.
(laughter)
- Right, and she looks, you
know, she's just got her
glasses on, she's ready,
she's got her notes,
she's starting to write things down.
And we're like, "is this
just a video" and then.
- Right, we knew it was
real because when we first
walked on she wasn't on
the screen but there was
like, a butler setting up
like, pudding, you know,
orange juice.
- Orange juice.
(laughing)
- And she just slid in in
her glasses like, "hello"
(roaring laughter)
- Henry's cheesecake.
(laughing)
- Hello cheesecake!
And I was like, "what!"
- Oh my god, you gotta talk
about cheesecake with Oprah?
- Yes.
- Yes!
(laughing)
(clapping)
- So amazing.
- That's my kinda woman!
- Yeah.
- Yes!
I don't want anybody up here
talking about kale salad,
I wanna talk about cheesecake.
- Cheesecake.
Henry's cheesecake.
- I knew I loved her.
Okay so, Rosario, do
you have an Oprah story?
- Well the first time I met
her was just doing her show,
because of doing press for Seven Pounds.
But my good story, I think, is being at
Critic's Choice Awards with
my mom, sitting next to Common
who was like, "you're mom's looking good!"
I was like, "yeah she is!"
And she was like, "excuse me
Common, Oprah's over there."
So we like went over to
Oprah's table and then she got
Ava DuVernay to take our photo.
I was like, "it's Ava DuVernay."
She's like, "it's Oprah."
I was like, "okay."
(laughing)
- So then we took a
photo, and my mom, because
I'm working on Ava's new
show, my mom goes, "ask Ava
to ask Oprah for the photo that
we took all those years ago"
I was like, "mom, why would she have."
She goes, "no, don't you
remember Oprah took it
on her Blackberry."
I'm like, "no she didn't
take it on her Blackberry,
why would she do that?"
She said, "no you just need to ask."
so I told it to Ava, Ava's
like, "I'll find the photo
of you."
I was like, "no, no,
none of this, got this!"
We'll try to take a new one,
we'll all take one together!
(cheering)
(clapping)
- Okay and we'll talk about cheesecake!
- I know, I was like, I
wanna come but only if
there's cheesecake, yes.
- [Alano] We'll make it happen.
- Thank you!
Dreams, check!